so you're saying we never lost
we're still fighting this war do you
I just came from a class taught by Bob
Herbert and he was saying how he was
painting this very bleak picture of
America kind of and essentially saying
what we need now to kind of fix America
isn't incremental reforms or maybe oh
not not just incremental reforms and not
just maybe a social entrepreneurship but
a full-out social movement like we had
in the 60s with the civil rights
movement or with the women's movement or
the labor movement what do you what do
you think about that do you think that's
what that's what's needed right now do
you think that's possible to be created
again I don't even think we have a
choice it's what will be regardless of
what you think regardless of what I may
think of feel they're they're
inevitabilities on the way that will
just roll over you because that's the
way history treats it this problem has
been in part of civil cycle forever I
mean when you talk about capitalism and
you're talking about free capital and
the flow of money and trade and
internationalism all that kind of stuff
a certain group rose up that we now see
as the capitalist class or the rich
people and they dominated the economics
of our of our societies well one of the
earliest glues to the success of that
economic process was the exploitation of
human beings and the first major
exploitation here in America of human
human property of human energy was what
we did to the Native Americans Europeans
came they conquered and they needed
cheap labor and a workforce and it
conscripted the Indians to fall in and
on the slave traditions force them into
extinction as a people cause they just
so cruelly treated them as cheap labor
as as commodity and not with a humanity
and when they ran out of that group and
they were extinguished or at least
removed
and a great totality they went out and
imported the next group of wage earners
and and workers and that was slavery and
that a century of that with black people
cheap no value no human value no worth
morally deficient and when that system
played itself out as much as I could in
that to be changed it then instituted
its next set of rules which are for
segregation and they had divide and
conquer and keep people still in that
cheap labor into that useless place of
life because the rich determined who you
were what you were to be called and how
you and jord now jumped today what
fascinates me is that in the 20th
century and Sofia the dawning of the
21st century we saw huge appeals we saw
the Soviet Union and the communist
Russia implode now everybody thought
that if that dynasty of that power were
to it all be eradicated would be in the
midst of bloodshed and tyranny and great
tragic forces clashing and nuclear war
but it came and went without a shot
being fired somebody you can say well
that's a coincidence to history but then
you say okay let's change the
environment let's change the scenario
let's go to a place where the issue is
race not economic oppression but race
and here in South Africa you had the
largest population of Africans a black
Africans being exploited by European
minority they cruelly with apartheid and
everybody expected when Africans got
free they would just destroy white
people in an act of vengeance but the
truth of the matter is the society
transformed and not a shot was fired and
people began to find ways in which to
integrate and come together because
those systems no longer work they
imploded they died out of their own
cholesterol then you look at so
any other things and what fascinates me
about America is we sit with some sense
of arrogance with the fact there they go
there go those empires there go those
extreme forces and we're the only ones
left and what's happening we are
imploding we are in a crisis that is
unique to all other crisises at least in
our time the economic collapse you're
looking at is because the system just
doesn't work and now it has nobody to
blame it's running on its own on its own
on its own juice and the more it does
the more it fails and whether it's
what's going on on Wall Street and
whether it's the way with they have run
off with the Treasury and whether
they're making laws and rules at further
or press you see I think that system in
a dying stage in a dying phase and
what's coming in is that force which
will replace whatever that system will
be replaced with and hopefully they'll
be the sanity that comes from an active
citizenry people who are great sense of
the common humanity and will help turn
Occupy Wall Street or occupying you
haven or occupy whatever because that's
what it is now people can have a rather
interesting intercourse with
intellectual debate and try to find
reason and rhyme and and then and
contain these things in ways that are
not applicable but the fact is that
these things happen when the civil
rights movement came into being we were
considered dirty people mindless
wasteful priors people who suck off the
state through all those things and yet
we change the nation and we changed the
value system of a country not
successfully and not completely but
successfully and these were the battles
that were being fought the war is still
there who were coming back now with a
new
the new energy and that puts all out of
this squarely on your on your plate
because you mentioned Julian Bond before
he was younger than you when we met and
in the movement Julian was 20 and a John
Lewis was 18 Diane Nash will let a lot
of snake in the movement was 17 and a
half years old with child and I know all
on campuses around American studying all
the things they were doing but they
abandoned that part of their social
experience and engaged in the issues of
social change and they did a hell of a
job and I would say now the balls on in
your court your turn what do you got for
me